[Music]
hello everybody
market buyer here um we just hit 300
thousand subscribers which is an
absolutely incredible thing if you think
about it because we got we hit 200
thousand subscribers on March 24th which
means that in less than a month we have
gotten a hundred thousand subscribers
and that is absolutely incredible that's
exponential growth if you if you could
ever call something that because exactly
let's see two months before that or
really close to two months before that
we just hit a hundred thousand
subscribers and then it took like I
don't know ten nine months to get to
100,000 subscribers it's it just blows
my mind what you guys have been able to
do in terms of helping this channel grow
and it is all because of you that that
I'm here and I'm so incredibly lucky to
have the fans that I do and to have you
guys supporting me because without you
well I'd probably still be doing it but
I just wouldn't be able to do as much
because if you think about the good that
we've done so far we've raised over
forty eight thousand dollars in terms of
charity and I've I never imagined when I
first started doing saying that I was
going to do it back in like July of last
year we've been on YouTube for over a
year now
um so it's just amazing to see how far
we've come and how you guys have changed
my life from something where I was you
know I wasn't exactly sure what I was
doing you know I was kind of just
wandering through trying to find
something worth you know fighting for or
really working my butt off to succeed at
and finally I found this thing that it
seems so random and yet entertaining
people on the internet can really be a
force for good so from from the bottom
of my heart I really do appreciate all
that you've done for
me I think back to some of them amazing
videos that people have made for me is
showing their gratitude for me which is
absolutely ridiculous because I have
nothing I have nothing really had to
show for that because I'm the only one
who feels indebted to you guys because
without you we wouldn't have been able
to raise the over 48 thousand dollars
for charity we wouldn't be able to
increase our goal month-on-month because
we raised $15,000 this month I don't see
any reason why we can't raise $20,000
next month and then I don't see why we
can't keep raising it month after month
getting more and more for charity and
that that really holds a special place
in my heart I just want you to know how
really truly grateful I am for the
opportunity that you've given me to show
that you know I could weave together not
just me we together can do something
great so truly thank you guys so much I
say thank you at the end of every video
but I want people to know that you know
you know this is more this is more than
just a fling for me there this isn't a
relationship I'm not breaking up with
you you can't leave me forever know this
true truly is something um that I am
passionate about this is something that
I'm eternally dedicated to like I'm
never gonna stop entertaining people in
the Internet I'm never gonna stop making
videos in one way or another I mean I
know YouTube will probably fade in you
know in 10 years or so and the the kind
of thing the way the internet works
things change so much but so long as you
guys are there and even if I'm gone even
if a me markiplier phase out I want you
guys to always remember the lessons that
we're trying to build here in the
community that we're trying to build you
guys need to know that you're more
powerful than than anything out there
you guys together when you work together
and band together and do something to
strive to make a change in the world
you're more powerful than anything up
and you need to believe in yourself when
you do that and I'm not talking about
the collective
talking about just one person because
just one person can truly change the
world so long as they believe that they
can I never thought that I could band
together you guys and I'm just I'm just
a start a lot of you people are are
really young and you've got your whole
futures ahead of you and you can really
dig down and now is the potential to do
so much more you can go out there and
literally do anything and I hope that
you know down the road maybe you know
whenever whenever YouTube shuts down or
whatever happens I hope you take these
lessons to heart that people can do so
much good for the world if we just start
caring about changing the world around
us we can do so much and I am so
grateful that right now and right here
we have this opportunity and I'm now so
I'm like I'm being sappy saying like
we're gonna end this is the end no we're
not we're not gonna end we're not gonna
end anytime soon but I hope that I've
impacted you guys's lives or at least
someone influenced you into trying to be
better because that's what I tried to do
I just try to be better every day I both
as a person and as an entertainer I try
I try to be better at what we do here
and I just want you to know that I'm a
better person because of you guys so
thank you truly and honestly
here's to 700,000 more to get to 1
million subscribers which is probably
going to happen sooner than I could
possibly imagine so thank you guys so
much from the bottom of my heart
I love each and every one of you I'm so
excited to wake up and see the new
comments and new emails and the letters
and and all the great gifts that you
guys have given me I just want to give
back whatever way I can so thank you
guys so much for watching and as always
I will see you in the next video bye bye